well all of this serious talk has gotten
me very eager to talk about something
you know a lot less serious patreon
losing
oh yeah now while we can talk about real
war and chaos and conflict in china
let's talk about culture war for those
that aren't familiar patreon as a
subscription service most of you
probably heard of it
it is a big tech run by a company run by
far leftists
they believe all this crazy
intersectional stuff like most of these
companies do
and they banned a bunch of moderates
conservatives you know
right individuals i don't know exactly
what to call these people because i'm
not gonna use
false labels on people i don't know they
banned them for hate speech
some of these were completely in my
opinion bs notably
sargon of akkad you may know sargon so
he had a patreon account
i believe he was getting around ten
thousand dollars per month from his
patrons yeah people choosing to give him
money
well some activists dug up a like
nine month old live stream of him at the
time it was very old
and at like the two hour mark in a four
hour stream he used the n-word
you know in in uh ironically to insult
people he thought were racist in a way
that he thought would offend them okay
someone sent that clip to patreon
and they banned his account without
warning and they had already promised
before they would never ban people
without warning
right right they were supposed to be
like hey don't do this again
so it wasn't on patreon it didn't
violate their rules
but they banned him anyway destroying
his income
now another user of patreon owen
benjamin
who according to the daily dot they call
him far right they call him whatever i
don't i don't know any i really don't
know anything about the guy
he got banned for hate speech except he
filed an arbitration claim against
patreon
and so did a whole bunch of he he told
his
patrons to do the same thing this would
have made patreon
front millions of dollars in legal costs
so patreon
sued his patrons and wait wait before
before they they sued back didn't they
change the
their taos they changed their terms so
they first they all got
patreon got sued they got no no they got
told they were there was going to be an
action against them oh okay okay so they
were prepared
so then there's their tos and guess what
the
the new term said that if you stay on
this platform then you agree to the
terms
yeah which is like unenforceable right
so then on the sixth
apparently they filed arbitration claims
patreon tried
arguing they have to pay the costs
according to the terms of the website
they argued no we don't because we are
you know
we're making claims against you based on
the terms as we signed up
patreon filed a lawsuit against the fans
to stop them because
this will destroy patreon and patreon
lost that motion
so now we are entering what may be one
of the greatest
get woke go broke stories of all time
wow patreon trying to enact these woke
social justice rules may result in a
massive
multi-million dollar silicon valley
startup going belly up
but it also means all of the left-wing
channels on the platform that
rely on patreon for their income will
lose all of their income
overnight yep this is going to be like
man i don't know how to describe it
there's a big battle going on and
there's a massive bridge a collapse on
everyone falls off of it
wow yeah because there's there's like
you know right-wing people use patreon
too
yeah take a look at this is a tweet from
mike cernovich he says update patreon
lost
the judge applied well-established law
and denied patreon's motion
cited against them in their lawsuit
against owen benjamin fans
patreon will now be forced to arbitrate
100 plus claims and pay
upfront fees of up to ten thousand
dollars per arbitration
and then to to drive that spike straight
in cernovich says
sargon of akkad could end patreon if he
had his followers file action similar to
the one owen benjamin fans did
that's it that would be the end of
patreon and will chamberlain added
lauren southern and milo too now there's
one very important point
mike cernovich and will chamberlain are
both lawyers oh
so i'll take their word for it i didn't
know that he's a lawyer okay yeah or
both of them are lawyers
sargon had thousands of fans on patreon
yeah
and most of them it's my understanding
canceled their accounts
when he got banned so you can't even try
and argue the new terms applied to that
because they left
because they left immediately before the
new terms were enacted wow
every single one of those people could
now file arbitration
for i i guess what owens owen benjamin's
fans said was tortious interference
i mean even if they are still on patreon
couldn't they not because of this
president
technically but the so i'm not i'm not
gonna pretend like i know i'm not a
lawyer right okay but my understanding
is that
patreon was served notice before they
changed the rules
that they would be getting oh okay these
claims okay so now if everyone came
forward
they would say you're only coming
forward now that you know
however it still might go through
right because the the the ruling i guess
is you can't
change now that patreon knows they're
liable for banning these people
the the judge would probably be like you
only change this because
you knew you slided all these people and
don't want to get sued you can't do that
yep exactly so even he did say that
isn't it isn't that what the judge said
to him
owen benjamin's uh fans gave notice
before they changed the terms right okay
so if now
you filed a claim they'd say they had
every chance to do so beforehand
like owen benjamin's fans they didn't
it's only after this they decide to do
it
that's not fair to us but i still think
they might lose on the grounds that
if i sign up to a site and i agree to
terms you can't arbitrarily send me an
email saying the
the terms have changed and you agree to
it well especially because sargon got
cancelled with no you know no warning in
the middle of the night
you're done yep cut out all your income
lost yeah and they had done this to
other people like lauren southern
the important point is again not being a
lawyer i
i would personally question the legality
of me
signing up for a website and it says do
you agree to these terms
yes and then a month later getting an
email that says oh by the way the terms
have all changed
you're on the hook to pay our fees and
if you use the website you agree
no i don't think that works i don't
think you can do that i think
you would need to have a new thing
appear saying hey before you come in
here the new terms you must agree to
these
i'm not sure exactly what patreon did
but my understanding is they sent an
email out saying by the way
if you're still using the site after
january 1st you agree to these terms
and the the judge was like nah get out
of here with that you can't
you can't do that no people signed up to
these terms
those are the terms you wrote this one's
on you
so here's what happens i like that judge
you got all these
sargon fans milo lauren southern now i
don't know if lauren southern's fans
you know will do they probably will i
don't know if lauren southern will care
to be involved in something like this
she recently started making videos again
but i don't know if she's going to be as
heavily culture wars used to
i think milo yiannopoulos and all of his
fans are going to
just torpedo it's going to be like open
season
and i'm pretty sure sargon's fans as
well this
is the biggest opening in the culture
war for a
massive counter move against silicon
valley big tech
let's do it well it's that
they can do it well i mean i i yeah i
can't either but
if you're if this applies to you call
now
sj and w lawyers will help hook you up
no no no they'll do it they're
just patreon's calling sjnw no i know i
listen i listened to this uh this
lawsuit
um the case patreon was arguing to the
judge and
and owen benjamin's lawyers to the judge
and the judge
right away was like you know you're
going to lose this
but he decided to consider some of the
facts basically what patreon's lawyer
said
that i'm pretty sure they said it
essentially verbatim
if you side with them we will be forced
to front
millions of dollars they straight up
said that yeah but if you do that we're
gonna have to pay for what we did
yep uh yeah no hold on throw the book at
him
to be fair there is a sympathetic
argument there of being like
we really really screwed up they
probably don't have a claim but
our company will cease to exist if you
side with them
get woke go broke period and the judge
said
president say it won't go broke no the
judge the judge's stance is probably
more like
i can sympathize with the fact your
company's about to cease it will no
longer exist after this
but the law matters to more than just
you
you made a mistake now you can live with
it
i wonder what's going on right now at
patreon they're probably all panicking
i'll tell you i'll tell you this man i
think the founder of patreon like jack
dorsey
likes zuckerberg these people are
evil i i you know i i hate using that
word but i use it because
they will look into your eyes and lie
sweet sweet lies all the time so the
term sweet nothings
they won't tell you so
jack conti is the ceo of patreon and he
put up so he banned lauren southern
lauren southern was on a boat in the
mediterranean and he said that she
crossed the line
when she said to get in front of some
ngo rescue vessel it's a very
long it's a long story i talked to him
on the phone
and i was in vegas at the time and i was
like i was tweeting about how i'm gonna
end my patreon
and people didn't know how much money i
was making on patreon at the time
because the numbers were private okay
and so people could only speculate based
on the amount but i had a few i had
several thousand patrons
so i ended up talking to the ceo and
he told me a bunch of things that were
just in my opinion not true
okay like what um well i can't i'm not
gonna it's private conversation you know
i can't well i'm not no that's fine no
no i get it if i go around
you know spilling the details of every
private conversation i never have
another conversation again i understand
but he did basically say things about
lauren southern's case which i did i
think i did talk about
that i was talking to him i was like you
realize you literally described what she
was like if she did these things
we wouldn't have banned her and i was
like uh that's literally what she did
well i mean i'm like nah listen the
problem is he banned lauren without
notice
there's god there's a sargon okay right
and so
once he banned lauren he was like she
can appeal
but then everyone basically said we're
going to quit because we can't risk our
income being terminated
without notice yeah and so he was like
from now on we'll give warning
and then sargon got erased overnight and
that's when there was a major revolt
dave rubin left jordan peterson left
sam harris like sam here is one of the
biggest podcasts in the world
and he was like i'm out i'm not going to
play these games because
if they decide to terminate my income i
can't take that risk
and now i got bad news for all of you
who still use patreon
i warned you i did i said
it's only a matter of time before you
face the brunt of what's happening here
now likely you'll be banned and i told a
bunch of people especially moderates
conservatives
and you know even not necessarily
political channels that were
like anti-sjw and i said
you need to get off patreon now they
have shown a complete willingness
on more than one occasion to terminate
the income of somebody without notice
and that's not fair because the
agreement i have is with my patrons not
with patreon
why are they getting involved in
politics well guess what's gonna happen
now
they're going broke if this really is
the end of patreon
if if sargon all of his thousands of
patrons
file arbitration claims and they have to
front the bill
lauren southern and milo were talking
about if if cernovich is saying
that a hundred plus claims is what
they're facing
and he said in a live stream it could be
15 to 20 million dollars because not
just the 10
it's 2 500 to 10 000 uh up front for the
cost of arbitration plus their own legal
fees their lawyers oh for their own
right
he said it could be 50 to 20 million
dollars up front
multiply 100 by 10. and then
if they lose well they might not lose
that's the issue
okay but the point is they still have to
pay for the legal fees if a hunt right
if a hundred people
will result in 15 million dollars in
costs
what will 3 000 people result in yeah
patreon going bankrupt overnight now
here's the best part
based on what we've seen from other big
networks that act as intermediaries
between creators and their money
i'd be willing to bet patreon will steal
the money in my opinion
will will take the money from the their
creators
to cover the cost of legal fees
otherwise their company doesn't exist
anymore
so i'll put it this way patreon makes
very little money
they they can show on their books
ridiculous sums of money
because when everyone donates it goes to
patreon then patreon has his massive
bank account and then pays it all out
and goes right back down
however if all of the money comes in at
once and patreon is holding you know 100
million dollars
they have to pay out 99 million right
because that's money's supposed to go to
the creators from their fans
but patreon is facing this major lawsuit
they're holding the money
first they're going to pay their legal
fees
all of that money they're holding will
disappear and then they'll tell the fans
sorry it happened sounds so brutal
oh it happened already somewhere there
was a multi patreon no
a multi-channel network these are big
companies where
youtubers will sign up and youtube
adsense goes to the company first
and then to you one of these companies
went out of business
and so when all the money from youtube
went to their company and they filed and
they declared like bankruptcy or
whatever i don't remember what they did
but they were shutting down
none of the youtubers got their money
because the money was the companies yeah
and the company considered the money
owed to the creators as liabilities
that they could not pay out so they used
the youtubers money to pay their
salaries and
my i i believe in the best of my you
know i'm very careful
yeah so in my understanding of the case
and i could be wrong about this so fact
check was that
they took the money to cover their own
losses and then all the youtubers were
like yo
where's our money it's gone so what do
you think patreon is going to do when
they're faced with something similar
they're going to need to find very
quickly 20 i mean right now 15 million
which i doubt they have who knows that
maybe
maybe but i doubt it maybe they'll find
some venture capitalists to try and save
them or buy them
and they're gonna have to cover the cost
of all of this nah i
i i don't think it's possible i think
they're going under man
i don't know man it doesn't the dominoes
are starting to crumble for the
the get woke broke it seems too good to
be true though true
that patriotism would would collapse
because of this yeah but i'll tell you
right now
patreon lost they did they're going to
have to front the legal fees and here's
the best part
that judge that judge props to that
judge flicked the first domino down well
he's just helping the law
exactly so here's the thing don't get
your hopes up other people have pointed
out that it's going to be a big waste of
money for everyone involved to file
against patreon
right and then you know it's it's you've
always got to take these things to the
grain of salt because i'm sure there's
going to be some lefty lawyer who's
going to argue why patreon will be fine
but here's my assessment based on
patreon's own
lawyer saying to the judge if we lose we
will be on the hook for millions of
dollars
and them losing i would bet that
cernovich is right
i think so too he's a lawyer too so i'll
defer to him but i heard the patreon
lawyer say it
we will have to front millions of
dollars if we lose this
that's a lot of dollars so the the
patreon was trying to argue that this
was an attack against them
that owen benjamin's fans knew that if
they filed
because of this law it would force
california uh california would force
them to pay the costs oh
you you mean hold them accountable for
what they what they illegally did
against their own terms of service well
now by booting these people
i don't know i don't know about
illegally because you
they they could boot whoever they want
okay the issue is
the so it's like these people want their
20 back
and so they're going to arbitration over
it demanding it and that means they have
to
give me a give me my 20 back that i gave
i gave to uh
owen benjamin and then you severed the
contract and now
where where's my you know my goods
aren't going to come right i see yeah
apparently there's another big factor
here in that by changing the terms of
service
to try and prevent these suits it was
now that's dirty right may have been
illegal i'm not sure again not a lawyer
but cernovich did a live stream about
this where he said it was unconscionable
or something
you know like as a legal term yeah okay
i i can't remember exactly what he said
dirty that's the loyal
you know the lawyer talk for it was
dirty trying to trick people in thinking
they don't have a way to take you know
legal action against you
right we'll see what sargon lauren and
milo do
yeah but more importantly it doesn't
matter what they do it matters what all
of the patrons who canceled their
accounts last year do
yeah because if they all decide i want
my money back because i spent money and
didn't get what i wanted because patreon
did this patreon owes me that money back
and patreon's foot in the bill so if if
you're one of those people i mean why
if i if i was one of those people and i
gave money to sargon
and you still have to file the claims
though which might cost money
okay yeah so apparently only a hundred
or so people from owen benjamin's fan
base
did this i don't i don't again like i
don't know a lot about the guy
i know that people are going to try and
claim i'm defending him i don't know who
he is okay
i own benjamin yeah apparently he's like
an offensive comedian or something i
don't know who he is
the daily dot called him alt-right i
don't know anything about the guy
i have to be careful because the media
likes to lie a lot but that's what
they've said
the point is how many people would be
willing
would be bored enough to actually do it
i'd be willing to bet enough
i was just gonna say there's not a lot
of jobs right now a lot of people are
stuck at home doing nothing well you
know the crazy thing is
what i don't based on everything i've
heard about this
i do believe it may sound too good to be
true because
even if you're going to lose in
arbitration you can still force them to
front the costs
that's a good point so what if you have
what if you know you're going to lose
that's another thing that patrons
lawyers argued that these people know
once it goes to arbitration they have no
case
but they still have to pay the fees up
front so
could anybody just file a claim and even
if they have no case
i guess there's got to be some kind of
standing yeah i mean i can't i can't do
it
right right right no but i mean like
i've been on patreon so what about all
of my patrons
you know what about me personally yeah i
lost a bunch of patrons because they
started ban when they banned lauren
people got mad when they banned sargon
people got mad
but then once sam harris left and dave
rubin
and jordan peterson banning sargon
lost me patrons because sargon and i
have some subscriber overlap
okay but then once it was sam harris
jordan peterson and dave rubin
all of a sudden i ended up losing like a
massive portion of my patrons
and i had no choice but to set up
alternatives like hey wait
go here i'll be here i know you guys
want to leave patreon so i ended up
losing
a lot wow yeah so just is patriot on the
hook for that
arguably no but those people who
canceled
from my account and from other accounts
because of this yeah maybe
i wouldn't know thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you